منذ اكثر من 30 عاما ومطرقته هذه لم تتوقف
زهير احد العاملين في سوق الصفافير من
القلائد الذين ما زالوا متمسكين بمهنه
تطويع النحاس والنقش عليه
وهي مهنه هجرها كثيرون هنا في هذا السوق
الذي يعد علامه مميزه لمدينه بغداد
القديمه لكن لم تعد حاله كما كانت
بالسبعينات قبل السبعينات
كله يشتغل
بالبدايه السوق شغلات طباخات مطباتات بس
الطباخات ما طباخات ادوات احتياط واصله
تقريبا من راس السنه
مسمي العراقيون النحاس في الصفر ومن هنا
جاءت تسميه سوق الصفافير
يشير اصحاب المهنه الى ان عدد المحل فيه
كان يزيد على المئه اما الان فانها لا
تتجاوز عدد اصابع اليدين
مثلا يعني ترى مو بس السياحه من الخارج من
الداخل احنا كان
والقوه الشرائيه للعراقيين يشترون اكثر
النفسيه
ورقم هذا التراجع فان السوق مازال يحتفظ
بالكثير من رونقه وعباق الماضي
لا يعرف على وجه الدقه متى اسس لكنه
تقارير تقول انه انشئ في عهد الدوله
العباسيه
يصنع السفارونا هنا هذه الحاجات التي كان
يستخدمها العراقيون في بيوتهم قبل عده
عقود اما الان فانها
فنيه يسعى كثيرون الاقتنائها وتزيين
منازلهم بها
كل تاريخ العربي القديم
في خيالك العوبه والاصاله والتاريخ
تواجه هذه المهنه العديده من التحديات
فبعض القائمين عليها يقولون ان ابنائهم
غير راغبين في تعلمها لانها لا تدر عليهم
ربحا وفيره اضافه الى غياب الدعم والرعايه
من قبل الدوله
من معالم بغداد التاريخيه وقديما قيل ان
من زار بغداد ولم يزر سوق الصفافير
والمنطقه المحيطه به فكانه لم يرى بغداد
على حقيقتها الخشيه ان يختفي هذا الجمال
يوما ما اذا استمرت حاله الاهمال هذا
وليد ابراهيم الجزيره بغداد